All right. This is not like a huge win where we
would throw a party and cheer, but we actually
got some good news, which is that Joe Biden's
budget nominee to run the Office of Management
and Budget, Neera Tanden, has had to withdraw
her nomination because of opposition. Now,
from the beginning, I said as we evaluated Joe
Biden's selections for all sorts of different
cabinet and other positions, Neera Tanden is a bad
pick. Neera Tanden was Joe Biden's worst pick, I
argued. And Joe Biden selected Neera Tanden to run
the Office of Management and Budget. It was pretty
clear early on that there would be opposition, not
just from many Republicans, but possibly even from
some Democrats. And indeed, that opposition
from both Democratic and Republican senators
made it clear that she was unlikely to be able
to get confirmed. Now, the reason let me say I
want to say this, although it's good that she's
not going to go forward and get confirmed, the
reason why most of the Republican in some of the
Democratic opposition didn't like her is kind of a
B.S. reason. And it's her controversial tweets
in which she attacked all sorts of different
people. She's attacked in tweets, everybody from
Bernie Sanders to many Republicans and others.
For me, the reason Neera Tanden was a bad pick was
because as someone affiliated with the Center for
American Progress, she represented she think about
all the things she didn't represent. Neera Tanden
didn't represent progressivism. Neera Tanden
didn't represent independence from the most
corporate and establishment interests within the
Democratic Party. She represented all of the worst
of Democratic Party politics and establishment
centrist leaning, kowtowing to the money
sort of individual who you were going to put
in charge of the budget. That was the source
of my opposition. I didn't care that Neera
Tanden had said mean things about Bernie. I
didn't care about Neera Tanden or other tweets.
The reason why so many Democrat Republicans and
even some Democrats like Joe Manchin said that
they don't like Neera Tanden for this position
was mostly related to tweets where all sorts of
different people who clearly didn't actually have
any idea what Neera Tanden was tweeting all along
sort of decided to grandstand on the basis of,
oh, look at this tweet that Neera Tanden, look at
that tweet that Neera Tanden sent. And ultimately
it became clear that Neera Tanden didn't
have the votes. Joe, mansion of an important
centrist swing vote among Democrats in the Senate
said that her, quote, overtly partizan statements
would have a toxic and detrimental impact on
working relationships between Congress and the
Office of Management and Budget. Maine Republican
Susan Collins also says that her, quote, past
actions demonstrated the kind of animosity Biden
has pledged to transcend. And it became clear that
they weren't going to have the votes for her. So
this is in a sense, funny, because on day one,
I mean, go back to my clip. The day after Neera
Tanden was nominated, I said not only do I think
this is a bad nomination, it's not clear to me
she can get confirmed because I believe there
will be opposition from Republicans and Democrats.
That's exactly what happened. It was predictable.
So it's not a huge win, but it's a win in
the sense that this was Biden's worst nominee
and she's not going to be in the position. And
that's a good thing. The next question becomes,
who replaces Tanden? The front runner is believed
to be Shalonda Young, a former staff director for
the House Appropriations Committee. And she's been
actively pushed by members of the Congressional
Black Caucus, believed to be the replacement pick.
I don't know much about Shalonda Young. We will
learn about Shalonda Young, if indeed she is the
nominee. By the time you listen to today's show,
maybe she will already have been made the
nominee. But as I said before, this is not,
you know. I don't know where this rant, like
if you said Biden could have done covid relief
10 days in and Neera Tanden would be director
of office, the Office of Management and Budget,
I might have said that's a fair trade. It
would have been like Neera Tanden bad. But
I might have traded it if you got me covid relief
really soon. And now we're still waiting on covid
relief. And it's March. It's a win. It's just
not feeling like this is now the progressive
takeover of the Biden presidency. But I think if
if you want to find something positive in this,
it would be that we can, as people to the left
of Biden, have an impact on the Biden presidency,
although, again, the reason that this
nomination tanked is partially because
Republicans didn't like her mean tweets, which
is not exactly a progressive perspective, but
that is what it is. Neera Tanden, not moving
forward and that I can be very glad about